- [Voiceover] Scoot a
little more and there.
- And her coochy's in my face.
(laughing)
(upbeat pop music)
- I don't identify with models.
- The ideal Abercrombie and Fitch model
is definitely, probably, white, hot.
- I mean I've never seen a trans guy
model anything professionally.
- I never see Indians.
- I have no boobs.
- I'm wondering like if, this will make
me feel more beautiful
or like, more wanted.
(upbeat pop music)
(voice covered by music)
- [Voiceover] It's hot as hell right now.
- Yeah, I do not smell good.
- My feet stink.
I do not think this is realistic.
- There's definitely some computers
going on with this stuff.
My knees hurt right now.
(girl laughing)
So yeah, It'll be
interesting to see myself
in that position that I
never really connected with.
- 'Kay, there it is.
This is our bodies.
- It was good.
- It was interesting just kind of
being naked and there's just
like people walking around.
But at the same time, it starts to
get empowering after a while.
- [Voiceover] I like it.
- [Voiceover] It's so crazy,
like you can see my scars and stuff
but I kind of like that,
'cause it's like yeah, we all have scars
and stretch marks and stuff.
It gives it character.
- It feels real, you know.
- [Voiceover] We place so much
emphasis on the naked body,
when it's like, at the end
of the day it's just skin.
- I'm a little uncomfortable, but I'm also
strangely comfortable in
a room full of strangers
on the internet, in my underwear.
As a dickless man, modeling
Calvin Klein underwear,
I think that's a first,
maybe, for the world.
- Yeah, I feel good, I
feel very glam, it's fun.
A company will choose a white woman
over a woman of color,
so I think the only way
to start to change that is
by just feeding people color
color instead of white faces
so that we're more comfortable
as a society with people of color.
- So my dad is Indian and my mom is white.
Growing up kids would tell
me that I was adopted.
Now that I'm older I feel so
much more confident in my skin
and this experience really allowed me
to embrace my skin color.
(gentle music)
- I'm excited, I think,
I think it's going to be good.
- I just know, I feel like I'm gonna
look like a big old dork.
- I'm excited.
- I'm a little nervous, I'm not gonna lie,
we were sweaty that day.
- Okay, ready?
(laughs)
- Like, we look so hot,
they're gorgeous and amazing,
but so are we.
- Wow, wow.
It's funny because I feel like this photo
makes me look like I'm just calm
and lying on a bed, when in reality, I was
breaking my back,
drooling all over my hand.
What you see is this one single moment,
when in reality, it was something else.
- The first thing I noticed that was
like strikingly different was hair.
For me, that's not my
ideal standard of beauty,
that dress is not really
a dress I would wear,
and because it's an ad it doesn't
really make me feel any more beautiful.
I kind of prefer the way
I look on a regular day.
(shrieks)
(laughs)
- You look hot.
My back rolls are definitely there.
He doesn't have any back
rolls, he has dimples.
- Even though it is me,
it's nice to see somebody
that's like every-day and
looks like me in an ad.
- Alright, well, I look better than
I thought I would honestly.
It would be cool if there was a trans guy
in an actual Calvin Klein ad.
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Seductively.
- When I look at fashion ads, I often
compare myself to them and
feel bad looking at them.
But I have to remember that I never
get professional hair and make up done
and all of those people do and they also
have Photoshop on their side.
- You know, there shouldn't
be one perfect type of body.
- I think we should be
able to live in a world
where both images can exist
and we're not fighting
for one to be the best.
They're just all there.